Bộ An Tung Phẩm, Bộ Y tế, vừa phát đi phuyên cáo người dân không xử dụng thức phẩm bảo vệ xức hoài xíu
an ngon 2 mẽ trong khi các cơ quan chức năng đăng tiến hạnh điều tra,
sắp mình vì phạm lên quan đến xình phẩm này.
Theo thông tin trên trang thông tin để từ của công an tính ninh bình ngày mấy bốn thằng sau năm 2020,
phòng cảnh sát kinh tế, cơ quan cảnh sát điều tra công an tính ninh bình đã ra quyết định hợi tổ vụ An.
Khởi tổ bị cán đôi với trên đại phúc, giám đốc công vi trách nhiệm hiểu hạn 2 mẽ và lưu văn hại,
cũng theo chào thông tin này, kết quả giám định đối với các chi tiêu chất lượng của thực phẩm bảo vệ xức hoài xíu an ngon 2 mẽ.
Sản phẩm gió công tý chất nhiệm hiểu hạn 2 mẽ công bố và sự chất nhiệm chất lượng sản phẩm xác định
các chất gồm vitamin A, cân xí, vitamin C, chất chính tạo nên công dụ của sản phẩm,
chỉ đặt dưới mấy mấy phần chăm sói với công bố.
Giòn đó, hai cả nhân trên đả bị cơ quan cảnh sát điều tra công an tính ninh bình khởi tổ thông vi định tại khoan một điều 1 trăm tri mê ba,
bố lột thình sự năm 2019.
Cung an tòa thực phẩm khuyến cáo người dân không nên sự dụng thực phẩm vào về xức hoài xíu an ngon 2 mẽ
của công tý chất nhiệm hiểu hạn 2 mẽ trong khi các cơ quan trức năng đăng sắp mình vụ biệt.